Every once in a while we do this where I tell
you some of the strange things that happen
behind the scenes here at the David Pakman
show and one of the things that we sometimes
do, it's, it's half funny, but I hesitate
to just call it funny because it's also kind
of concerning and sad is when people cancel
subscriptions for what seem like odd reasons.
And this is my opinion, maybe these are not
odd reasons to cancel a subscription.
And sadly as the show audience has grown dramatically
over the last year, the sort of unusual reasons
for canceling have also grown dramatically.
And I want to give you a couple of examples
today.
Last week, as you might recall, I said, Iowa
can't keep going first in the democratic primary.
It just can't happen.
And I laid out the first primary shouldn't
be a caucus.
The caucus system maybe should be abandoned
altogether.
Iowa demographically is not representative
of the United States nor the democratic party.
And yes, the fact that they so bungled things
on Monday night last Monday night also is
more of a reason for Iowa not to go first.
And I gave this disclaimer, which a lot of
people said, David, that's a dumb disclaimer.
You don't need to do that.
Where I said, Hey guys, I just want to be
clear.
I'm not attacking Iowans here.
This is not a personal attack on individuals
who live in Iowa.
Iowans are great people.
Uh, as far as I've met, met, you know, a few
dozen of them in my life.
This is not about people from Iowa, a political
analysis and someone canceled because they
said I was insulting people from Iowa.
In that segment, I got an email that said,
quote David, I'll probably not listen to your
show again.
I was a paying subscriber.
I'm from Iowa.
I saw your video about how undeserving Iowa
is of going first with the caucuses.
Insulting Iowa Democrats is disappointing.
I've long heard about rural America feeling
insulted by the democratic party and I've
ignored it, but the democratic party in this
state has had a clear openness to progressive
candidates, more so than a then a majority
of the States in the country, I believe they
meant.
And you and your audience's willingness to
be little.
The Democrats in this state, despite our boat
voting for Bernie and Obama is frustrating.
I'll just tune into the young Turks and Sam
Cedar from now on.
Their takes were more measured.
This is trouble guys, that someone would watch
that segment and someone who is at least apparently
on our side believe that it was about insulting
Iowans as individuals either didn't understand
the segment or something else is going on
and it is very, very sad.
Another recent one is someone who doesn't
like that.
I don't think Ford vehicles are that great
even though I don't even remember the last
time that this came up.
I recently got an email that said, David,
stop bad mouthing Ford vehicles.
It happened twice when I was a member on your
bonus shows.
I will never subscribe if you bad mouth Ford
again.
I truly appreciate this viewer support while
I had it, but if I don't even remember what
I said, but if merely saying, I don't think
Ford makes the best cars, which I don't.
I mean I, that's certainly my opinion and
I don't remember exactly what I said.
If that warrants canceling a subscription
to a political show that you otherwise are
online in line with, we're in trouble.
That's the reality.
I don't know how you can watch any show if
something this minor is a catalyst for abandoning
that program.
Just one more here, David.
As soon as you said that tool, see Gabard
had no chance on the Iowa livestream.
I had to cancel my membership.
She is the only candidate who will end forever
Wars and I can't believe you are attacking
her in this way.
Now this email is problematic in general,
like in an election with 10 candidates.
Some have no chance and canceling because
I point that out is not ideal, but the person
is saying they canceled because on February
3rd I said Tulsa has no chance during the
Iowa caucus result livestream.
She obviously had no chance at that point.
She got zero in the Iowa caucus.
So this is really disturbing stuff.
We deal with it.
You know, mathematically this is a small portion
of the audience, but it does concern me because
of what it suggests about the fickle nature
of the movement.
And fortunately it applies to a tiny, tiny
sliver of the audience, but I, this is not
concern trolling, this is not, this is nothing
other than that really does concern me because
when we think about we need everybody on board
to defeat Donald Trump, everybody, right?
Really, because we need to so overwhelm, overwhelm,
the meddling and the voter suppression and
all of this stuff that when someone says,
I'm abandoning a show that I guess I used
to agree with because they said something
about Ford or I misunderstood a story about
Iowa's attacking Iowans or I stated correctly
that tools, he had no chance of winning in
Iowa on the day that she got zero votes.
If these are reasons to abandon a show, I
am very worried about what will happen in
terms of abandoning a movement that wants
to remove Donald Trump as the top priority.
It's, it's sad and it's scary to me quite
frankly.